تنظيم حزب العمال الارهابي ليس تحديدا
لوحده التراب التركي فحسب بل انه تهديد
لوحده التراب السوري والعراقي ايضا ونحن
مصممون على اجتذات هذه المنظمه الارهابيه
من الجذورها
[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم مع استمرار لعمليه
العسكريه التركيه الشماليه سوريا اردوغان
يدعو لانهاء ما وصفه بلعبه دعم حزب
الاعمال لكردستاني وامتداداته التي قال
انها تتخفى تحت الستار مكافحه تنظيم
الدوله والاداره الذاتيه لشماليه والشرقيه
سوريا
بعرف عنيفه في دنيا الشرقيه اوكرانيا كيف
تعد الاجلاء السكاني خرسون الى غربه
البلاد بسبب القصف الروسي ورئيس الاوكراني
يطلب مواطنه بالاستعداد لشتاء طويل تتخلله
هجمه روسيه جديده
جماهير ترفعوا صوره نجم المنتخب الالماني
السابق مسعود اوزيل اثناء مباراه المانيا
واسبانيا في استاد البيت في رد كما يبدو
على حركه تكميم الافواه والزواجيه معايير
اللاعبين الالمان بحسب مراقبين يذكرون
اوزيل اعتزل اللعب بعد تعرضه الهجمات
عنصريه بسبب اصوله التركيه الى اللقاء